in this course you will learn how to
build a powerful CRM application using
Django Python and MySQL you also learn
how to use Version Control with Git and
GitHub and how to configure MySQL for
your application John Elder teaches this
course he is an experienced instructor
who has created many popular courses
what's going on guys John Alder here
from codemy.com and in this video we're
going to create a basic CRM app with
Django and python
all right guys like I said in this video
we're going to build this basic CRM app
with Django and python but before we get
started if you like this video you want
to see more like be sure to smash like
button below subscribe to the channel
give me a thumbs up for the YouTube
algorithm and check out codemy.com where
I have dozens of courses with thousands
of videos to teach you to code use
coupon code YouTube 50 to get 50 off
lifetime membership it's all my courses
videos and books for one-time fee which
is insanely cheap all right as like I
said in this video we're gonna build
this basic CRM tool with Django and
python CRM customer relationship manager
management you know what I'm talking
about this will allow us to add customer
records see John Elder address city
state ZIP code date created anything
else you want phone number or whatever
and then add it to the database we can
click on one of these guys and we can
see the record we can update the record
if we want so John 2 update this record
boom John 2 Elder if we want to we can
update the record back
there we go uh we can come down here
maybe we don't want a record anymore we
can delete it
record is deleted successfully we've got
this nice table when you hover over it
it sort of changes color so you can sort
of play around with it and it's very
cool we can log in and log out so we
could also register so you can create
accounts log in
see I'm as admin here and then here we
go so that's we're going to be building
this video this should be a complete
video I'm going to start at the
beginning go all the way through it and
this should be a lot of fun so let's
head over to our terminal I'm using the
Sublime Text Editor and the gitbash
terminal as always and as always you can
find a link to the code in the pin
comment section below so check that out
if you're interested so I've just got a
basic get bash terminal opened up and uh
you can see I'm just in my default
directory so let's create a directory
we're going to hold all this stuff so
I'm going to say mkdir I want to put it
in my C drive and I'm just going to call
this uh Django CRM dcrm whatever so now
we need to move into that directory so
CD
dcrm and when we do when we type in LS
to list the stuff here there's nothing
in there so all right that looks good
now I should mention before we get
started I'm going to be using a mySQL
database for this one just because I get
a lot of requests from my Sequel and
Django and I don't really understand
when that happens because the point of
Django is that it abstracts away the
database layer so it doesn't matter what
database you use you can use any data
base it's irrelevant you're not going to
be doing like my SQL commands in this
you're just going to be doing regular
Django database coding but I keep
getting questions about the mySQL
database so that's we're going to use in
this video you could swap this out for
postgres most people will use postgres
because when you push this online
postgres is the most popular and easy to
use database with Django and everything
else but you can use MySQL too it just
takes a few extra steps to get it going
so we're going to be using my SQL this
one just to mix things up a little bit
and it should be fun but like I said if
you want to use postgres it's very
simple to swap out postgres instead it's
just basically a couple of settings that
you need to configure so no big deal so
all right let's head back over here and
let's first create a virtual environment
we always create a virtual environment
so I'm going to go python Dash m v e n v
and let's call our virtual environment
vert sure for virtual hit enter this
should spin right up all right so now
when we hit LS we can see there's a vert
directory so let's turn this on let's go
Source vert scripts activate so now we
see this vert here so that we know the
virtual environment has been turned on
so all right let's pip install Django
the first thing we need
all right we're good there now we also
want to pip install MySQL
now we're also going to have to actually
download MySQL onto your computer from
their website we'll look at that in just
a second but uh we'll need to do that
next we need a connector to connect our
Django app to our MySQL app so there's a
couple of them so you can pip install
my SQL Dash connector that's the
original one go ahead and try that and
you may be fine but more likely than not
you're gonna have to install pip install
MySQL connector Dash python so I know
I probably need that
but
if for good measures you can install the
regular one as well if one of them works
the other one won't be needed and vice
versa so okay we're good there okay so
now we need to download and install my
SQL so I'll put a link somewhere to this
let's head over to a web browser and
just head over to this website
dev.mysql.com forward slash downloads
forward slash installer and we want the
MySQL installer for the community
version right and it's 437 megabytes go
ahead and click here to download now I'm
not going to do this because I've
already downloaded it's a little bit
tedious process you have to click next a
bunch of times and it installs a bunch
of stuff takes like five or ten minutes
to install this thing the important
thing here is when you install it it
will ask you to set up a username and a
password and root is probably the
username you're going to want to set up
it may default to root but if it doesn't
type in root for the username and for
your password pick whatever you want but
remember that password because we're
going to need it to connect to the
database later on in our Django app so I
think mine is just password one two
three so whatever for the purpose of
this that's fine but you know pick a
good password now once you install it
you'll need to turn it on there's
probably an option that says at the very
end you know start my sequel click yes
it needs to be running sort of in the
background you won't notice that it runs
in the background of windows so just
make sure that's turned on so okay let's
now head back over to our terminal all
right so let's head back over to our
terminal I'm still in my cdcrm directory
our virtual environment is still there
it's still turned on let's go ahead and
create our project so let's go Django
Dash admin start project and I'm just
going to name this dcrm
so now we see this dcrm directory so now
I'm going to change directory into it so
so CD change directory into dcrm and we
can see here's our manage.pi file so
that's cool so now we need to create an
app inside of our project so let's go
python manage.pi start app and let's
name this website because basically this
is a website so I'm just going to call
it website so now when we LS we could
see there's that directory so okay we've
got our stuff now let's head over to
Sublime Text and add all this in come up
to project add folder to project
navigate to your C drive and then find
that dcrm directory double click it go
inside of it click the second one just
once to highlight it click select folder
and boom there we go so the first thing
we need to do is make some changes to
our settings.pi file so I'm going to get
rid of our comments here and let's come
down here to installed apps we need to
add our app so we call that website
there we go now we need to come down
here and configure our database section
because by default Django uses sqlite3
but we want to use like I said my SQL
for this one so we need to make some
changes the Django DB back ends should
be pointed to my SQL now and we can get
rid of this
but we need to add some things first we
need to add a name so I don't know what
you want to name your database let's
call it I don't know Elder Co something
like that Elder company whatever name it
whatever you want and then now we need
to set the user and this is the user
that you set up when you installed my
SQL so it should be root or whatever you
set up next we need to designate the
password
and again that's that same password you
set up when you installed my SQL mine
was password one two three pick
something better than that
I'm just doing this on my local computer
so it doesn't really matter next we need
to set the host
so
this is just on our local computer so
it's going to be a local host
and then finally we need to set the port
my sequel generally runs on Port
3306 and that looks good you can I think
maybe change that during installation of
my SQL but you don't want to just take
the default so okay go ahead and save
this and we're good to go there so now
we need to set up that database that we
just designated remember we called it
Elder Co right we need to create that so
what I'm going to do is come back to my
terminal and we're in our dcrm dcrm
directory it's the same one that has our
manage.pi file right and I'm just going
to create a file using the touch command
and let's call this mydb dot Pi there's
lots of different ways you could do this
but this is really kind of the easiest
in my mind so we'll just do that head
back to our Sublime Text and you can see
there is our file so really quickly let
me just comment in some things we've
done so far so we want to install MySQL
this is the URL to the installation
thing we want to pip install MySQL we
also need a connector so either the
basic one or more likely this one
whichever one works on your computer try
them both maybe try this one to begin
with if it doesn't work try this one in
my case I know I I need this one on my
computer so I just would do that one but
you could try them both there's no harm
in that so now we need to import MySQL
dot connector
okay
that's this guy or this guy they both go
by that and we need to create a database
connection so I'm going to create a
variable called database and this is
going to be a MySQL dot connector
dot connect
and then inside here we need to
designate some things so host is we know
localhost and then our user we know is
root
and our password is now notice this is
past WD pass would not password that's
just the convention we know that that is
going to be password one two three
because I'm very lazy all right and
there we go so now we want to prepare
a cursor object and this might seem like
a lot of work but it's really not too
bad just a few more lines of code so we
want a cursor object and we want to set
that to database dot cursor
and that database is this thing right
here that we just defined right
we also now need to create the database
right so we can do that by calling this
guy
paste that in dot execute
and this is just a MySQL command to
create a database
we just create database and what do we
want to call it we want to call it Elder
Co right
now we can give a little message here to
the terminal if we want all done
something like that and go ahead and
save this file so we're only going to
need this right now one time just to
sort of set up this database and if you
know how to set up a database by hand in
the terminal you could do it that way
too or you could go to the MySQL
workbench and do it there however you
want to create your database you can but
this is super easy so I'm just going to
do it like this so let's head back over
to our terminal here and if we LS we see
sure enough there's that file so let's
just run it so let's go python
mydb.pi and boom it says all done and we
should be good to go now if you want to
confirm this you can open up your MySQL
workbench and let's see here
we could come down here to schemas and
when we hit refresh we see now there's
an elder Co
database in there right so okay that
looks like it worked so all right we're
pretty much done with the MySQL stuff
that's the extent of all the MySQL stuff
we're going to have to do uh we're
pretty much good to go now we can make
sure this worked by coming up here
clearing the screen and running python
manage.pi migrate because by default
Django comes with a bunch of database
stuff that needs to be pushed into the
database with a migration right out of
the box so we could do that now and if
this works boom boom boom we should be
all good to go now we can again confirm
this if we want in our MySQL workbench
we can click on tables and you can see
now there's a bunch of Django stuff in a
table in our Elder code database right
so that looks like it worked and we're
good to go so
all right that looks good one last thing
I want to do in this sort of area is
create a user so to do that
I'm gonna go win PTY and then python
manage.pi create super user
now I'm using the win PTY command
because I'm on Windows and get bash and
you have to if you're on a Mac or
something else Linux you can leave off
this win PTY and the command is just
python manage.pi create super user so
let's do that and I want to set the
username to admin and we don't need an
email address and then set a quick
password
okay we're good to go so now
let's run our server and see if this all
works so python manage.pi runs server
that looks good head back over to the
browser and when I hit reload here at
localhost 8000 boom we get this Django
start screen which means everything
works out and we are good to go so we
have set up our project everything is
working we've got a mySQL database
installed and connected and we're ready
to start building this thing out
so before we start building this thing
out let's set up Version Control very
quickly with Git and GitHub just so you
guys can check my code as I'm going
along if you want to watch that so to do
that we head back over to the terminal
hit control and see at the same time to
break out of our server and now we just
need to set up git and I've already got
an SSH key created on my computer if you
don't know how to do that check the
channel there's tons of videos on
setting up an SSH key you need an SSH
key to connect to GitHub I've also got
lots of videos on connecting to GitHub
for the first time if you don't know how
to do that so I'm just going to run
through this as if you already know so
head over very quickly to this webpage
codemy.com forward slash git these are
the commands to set up git on a project
and I never remember them I just come to
this page and uh copy and paste them so
this is the first one we just need to
copy each of these and paste them into
the terminal real quick so head back
over here right click paste and enter
your name John Elder hit enter boom that
one's good the next one is email address
so copy that head back over here
right click paste and here's my email
address
johnny4196
gmail.com I suggest you use the same
email address that you use at GitHub
this makes things easier
next we have this guy's copy him
and like I said I don't remember what
these commands do I just know that every
time we want to set up git we need to
paste them in so that's what I do I've
been pasting these commands in for like
20 years they never change and I still
don't really know or care what they mean
that's just what we do so add back over
here
paste enter and the last one I do
remember the last one it is get a knit
so there we go here
boom boom get a knit okay so now we see
this master on here that's the master
branch that means git has been basically
uh installed and it's been turned on so
now we need to put all of our files in
there so let's go get add period git
commit Dash am let's call this the
initial commit
all right so we've committed it all now
we need to push it up to GitHub and in
order to do that we need to go over to
GitHub real quick so go to github.com
login
so my username is I think flat Planet no
I don't think the world is flat I just
find it hilarious some people do okay
and then click on repositories
and then let's create a new one and I'm
gonna call this Django CRM and this will
just be public so we'll click create
Repository
and then we need to come down here to
push existing repository from the
command line and we need to enter these
commands into our terminal one at a time
so let's paste this guy in
alrighty then this one will change the
name of our Master Branch from Master to
Main
common now
so you can see now it says main there
and then finally the last one is just to
push all of our code up to GitHub
we'll grab this guy paste it in
and boom that looks good so now when we
come back here and hit reload
you can see here's all the code that we
have so far and we can confirm that we
can click this dcrm go to settings you
can see up there it says website we made
that change and then we come down here
and see up here's all the database stuff
Elder co root now your password is right
here this is open so if you're doing
this professionally when you set up your
repository you want to probably set that
up as private right so remember I picked
public
um but we can let me show you here again
go to repositories
click new name it and then right here
where it says public instead you would
click private so people won't be able to
see your code right but for our purposes
I don't really care I don't care that
you guys know that my mySQL database is
password123 there's nothing in there you
can't hack it well I suppose you could
hack it but there would be no reason to
there's nothing interesting in there so
there you go so okay that looks good
so all right we're moving right along so
now let's come back here and let's run
our server so python manage.pi run
server
head back over to the website make sure
that's working hit reload okay we're
good to go there so all right let's
start building this thing out so let's
head over to our code now you could
delete this mydb.pi file we do not need
it at all anymore I'm going to leave it
in here just so you guys can reference
it if you want if you head back over to
github.com
planet and then click on the Django CRM
director you can see here it is right
there if you want to copy and paste it
or whatever you can do that so okay so
let's start to build this thing out
so let's head over to our code and start
building this thing out so I can close
out our dcrm folder we're going to be
working mostly from now on in our
website folder here so actually know
that we do need to do one thing first in
this folder that we didn't do we need to
play around with our urls.pi file so
open up this file
and here we need to add include
and we go there and we need to create a
new path so I'm going to call this two
single quotation marks nothing in
between them and we want to include
our website
dot URLs file
right now we don't have a URLs file in
our website directory yet we need to
create that so I'm just going to copy
all this and close this head over here
to our website directory right click new
file and then file save as and let's
call this urls.pi
and paste in that code now we don't need
this and we don't really need this
include and we really don't need that
okay so let me minimize this dcrm
directory again we're not going to be
using that much at all if at all from
now on and okay so instead of this
thing right here let's create a new home
page so anytime in Django when you want
to create a web page it's always a
three-step process you create the actual
template file the actual HTML page you
also create a URL and you create a view
so let's start out with creating a URL
right here and this is going to be our
home page so we could just so we just
want it to be in root which is nothing
just two single quotation marks and we
want to point this to views dot home
let's call it and let's give this a name
equal to home now up here we need to
import our views so let's go from period
import views
okay so this is our URL we're good there
now let's head over to our views.pi file
and let's create our home page view so
let's define home we want to pass in our
request as always
and then here for now we just want to
return
render
request and then we want to point this
to home.html now this doesn't exist yet
but we'll create it in a second and we
want to pass an empty context dictionary
so okay that's good there now we need to
create this home.html file so let's head
over to our website directory right here
right click and create a new folder and
then down here at the bottom let's name
it templates now Django knows to look
for all web page files in the templates
directory so it will just know to look
there so we can create a new file file
save as and we want to call this
home.html and for now I'm just going to
say uh hello world just to make sure
this is working
go ahead and save this now we can head
back over to the website and click
reload and hopefully that worked oh we
got an error because let's see no model
named website URLs ah let's go ahead and
break out of our server run it again now
that should work
just need a little reset there when we
made a change there to the settings.pi
file and boom there we go hello world so
we've got our first web page so very
cool now let's set up the base.html file
and a base.html file is just the file
that every web page on your site will
reference and it'll pull like the
headers and the Footers out of right so
I'm going to come over to templates
right click new file file save as we
want to call this base.html and inside
of here we want to put all of the code
that's going to go on every page so the
code we're going to use for our styling
is something called bootstrap the
bootstrap CSS framework it's the most
popular CSS framework and we can use
that for free by going to
getbootstrap.com clicking on the docs
and then just coming down here and we
want the one with CSS and JavaScript so
I'm just going to copy this to clipboard
and then we just want to come back here
and right click and paste all of this
stuff into our base.html file and up
here the title let's change this to
Django CRM something like that and then
here where it says hello world we need
to take this out and add a little tag
and the tag we want to use is a Django
tag and it's the block content tag
right so that's the opening block
content tag we also need a closing one
so type in in Block here all one word
and basically what this does is it will
pull everything out of our web page in
this case all we have in there is this
stuff it will Django will basically pull
stuff out of there and it will place it
inside of this tag right but it'll do it
behind the scenes so okay that's cool
now we need to come back over here and
make a quick little change we need to
say hey use that file right so up here
at the top we want to extends
base.html
right and then in this page we need to
wrap everything that we want that
based.html file to use inside that same
block content tag so here we can just
type that in real quick so that's block
content
and then again we need to close that tag
down here so end block okay go ahead and
save this make sure that base.html file
has been saved so now let's head back
over to our website and see if that
works now notice the text it's all kind
of Blocky and dark if we click reload oh
we get an error ah I didn't put a
quotation mark at the end of that
uh head back over to our home yeah there
we go right there typos
I'm the master of typos it's gonna
happen a lot all right so boom now you
see the text is skinnier it's kind of
not as blocky that means bootstrap has
been installed and we're good to go so
all right that looks good now this is
shoved right up here in the top we need
to change that a little bit and we can
do that by going over to our base.html
file and wrapping this whole thing in a
bootstrap div called
container
right like that and we need to close our
div there we go and if you want you can
tab this over to make it look pretty so
now if we save this and head back and
hit reload boom it pops it over a little
bit you might also want to add a little
line break or something so I'll just add
a br line break tag come back over here
hit reload boom and we're good to go so
all right that looks good now let's
create a nav bar so let's head back over
to our templates directory right click
and create a new file I'll save as let's
call this
navbar.html and we're going to grab that
from bootstrap as well because it's
super easy head it back over to
bootstrap scroll down to components and
then look for navbar now there's navbar
and navs and tabs you don't want navs
and tabs you just want nav bar so I'll
go ahead and click that and then just
come down here and find one that you
like I like this one right here so we'll
go ahead and copy this
and we can head back over to our
navbar.html right click and paste all
this in so let's just go ahead and save
this and see what we got right out of
the back now we need to add this to our
base.html file so we'll come back over
here and right under the body tag let's
add another Django tag called include
and here we could just include our
navbar.html close your quotation mark
there and that should be it so let's go
ahead and save this head back over here
and let's hit reload and boom we've got
a navbar so okay looking good now let's
modify this nav bar because I don't like
light nav bars so let's go ahead and
change that so let's head back over here
and go to our navbar.html and up here at
the very top where it says BG body
tertiary we can get rid of that
and instead let's type in navbar dash
dark and BG Dash dark so that will
change it from light to dark so if we
come back over here and reload boom I
think that looks much better so okay
let's play around with this let's
navigate let's modify this bar a little
bit more and we can start with this
navbar guide instead of it saying navbar
let's call Django CRM and instead of
pointing to hashtag let's point this guy
to
a URL tag pointing to our home page
all right okay let's go ahead and save
this and back over here hit reload all
right now if I right click and open in a
new window it goes to the home page
right we can click it forever and it
just keeps going to the home page so
that looks good next let's get rid of
the search thing I don't think we're
gonna need that
come down here to the bottom of our nav
bar and see this search come up until
let's see yeah you see you can click on
form in the closing form tag appears
that's how you know kind of you know
what to delete so you just highlight and
delete it save it come back over here it
reload all right that's gone next let's
get rid of this disabled link same deal
just come back over here and kind of
look for the word disabled there it is
go up above click on this Li the closing
Li tag highlights you can see there's a
little line underneath it so that's
again how we know what to delete
save that and I like to do one little
thing at a time to make sure I didn't
mess something up so we've got this drop
down thing we don't need that so again
let's head back over here look for the
word drop down ah there it is and then
come up see we don't even really need to
know HTML we could just sort of eyeball
this and when I click on this Li this
closing Li tag way down here highlights
so I know
all of this can go
save that and back reload all right and
now we've got these links we are going
to need some links up here so I want to
use this one and not this one I just
like the the look of the sort of
more muted one right there so let's get
rid of this home link instead again come
back here look for the word home there
it is click on the LI tag Right Above It
the closing tag highlights
we can get rid of it save it
come back over here boom all right we're
good to go so we are moving right along
we've got a functioning website we've
got a home page we've got a nav bar
things are starting to come together now
I think we want to add the ability to
register as new users log in and log out
so I think we'll look at logging in and
logging out first and then we'll do
registration that's a little bit more
complicated there's a little more stuff
involved logging in and logging out is
relatively simple and that's because
we're going to use the Django
authentication system this comes with
Django it will do all of the heavy
lifting for you it will take care of
logging people in logging people out
keeping track of who's who and what's
what and it just comes with Django and
it's really easy to set up and use so
we're going to do that now
so let's head back over to our code
and let's close out some of these things
just because so we need to import the
Django authentication system into our
app so let's come up here to the top of
our views.pi file and let's go from
django.contrib dot auth short for
authentication we want to import several
things first authenticate
then also log in and log out and while
we're at it we want the ability for
Django to flash up little messages on
the screen so like when somebody logs in
we want to flash up a little message
that says you have logged in you know
when it logs when you log out we want to
flash up a little message that says
you've logged out see ya whatever when
we register we want to flash up a
message that says you've been registered
successfully whatever all that good
stuff so we need to import that too so
let's go from
django.contrib we want to import
messages plural
and that looks good so we've already got
a user we set up a super user and if we
come back over here we can go to the
admin section of Django and we can log
in with that user right so we don't need
to register that user we've already got
it so we can log that user in and out so
I'm going to go ahead and log out but
that's why we can do the login and log
out stuff before we set up the
registration because we've already
registered a user now what you're going
to want is to be able to register users
on the web page not on the back end like
we did when we set up the super user way
back at the beginning of this thing so
we'll build all that out in a little bit
but we're going to start like I said
with logging in and logging out so
what we need here is a couple of
new views so I'm going to Define login
underscore user I want to pass in the
request
and for now I'm just going to say pass
and we want to Define log out underscore
user again we want to pass in the
request
and if you're not familiar with what a
request is anytime you go to a website
you're requesting that website you're
requesting that web page that request
gets sent back into the back end right
here and we pass it into the view and
then return something in this case we're
returning the home page so that's what
this request is you see a request a lot
in Django and just think of it as that
somebody going to a web page and
requesting that web page right so that's
all that is so okay we've got these two
new views we also need URLs because like
I said it's always a three-step process
in Django you need a view you need the
thing you know like that and you need a
URL so let's head over here and create
our URLs open our urls.pi file and I'm
just going to copy this and paste it a
couple more times so let's create a
login
URL and this is going to point to views
Dot Login underscore user that we just
created in our views.pi file and let's
name this login
okay so that's good we also want to log
out
right and this is going to be views DOT
log out User it's very complicated right
log out user and we want to give this a
name of log out now the reason why I'm
calling this logout user instead of just
log out is because here we're importing
login and log out and these are
basically functions that will run so our
view can't be named log in because it
will conflict with this login thing it
can't be named log out because it will
conflict with log out so we you know get
around that by calling it login user
instead of just login so that's why we
do that so all right head back over here
this looks good go ahead and save this
now head back over to reviews.pi file
and I've created this login user
function and if you want to create a
separate login page you need that but I
think we're just going to add this to
the home page so what we want to happen
is if somebody comes to the home page if
they're not already logged in we want to
flash up a form that says login if they
are logged in we want that form to
disappear here and we just want to show
the database like the CRM list of all
the records but we don't want to show
those records unless you're logged in so
we will do this all on the home page so
let's head back over here and we can add
all this stuff in our home view so
before we do that let's add the form to
our home.html page just so we can see
what we're looking at here head over to
our home.html so and let's Center this
form in the middle of the screen so I'm
going to give this a div with a class
equals and this is going to be col Dash
md-6 and this is just pure bootstrap and
then we also want to give it a space and
then give it an offset Dash md-3 and
basically like I said this is just
bootstraps code that says Center
everything in the middle of the screen
so if we just save this and head back
over here and click reload
well we got rid of this login view so we
need to modify this very quickly head
back over to urls.pi file and we don't
actually need that guy anymore so we can
comment him out and for now we'll
comment this out because we haven't
built this out yet and I'll throw an
error so if we save this head back over
here now if we hit reload we can see
boom hello world is more centered than
it was before and that looks good so
let's head back over here to our home
page and let's start building this thing
out so there's a couple of ways to
create forms in Django you can create a
forms.pi file we'll do that later with
the registration you can also just hand
code it we'll do that for this I want to
do both of them in this little video
here so you can see both ways to do it
so here let's just change this to log in
and let's create a form and the method
we want for form is post anytime
somebody fills it out and clicks the
button it posts that to the server and
then we also want to give this an action
of
and this is going to be a Django URL
and we want to point it to home because
we want to send those back to the home
page right so then down here we can
close our form tag anytime you create a
form with Django you also need a csrf
underscore token that's a cross-site
request forgery token it helps your form
from getting hijacked by hackers so
that's just a requirement now let's
create a form and we're going to use
bootstrap for this so I'm going to head
back over to bootstrap and come up here
to forums and click overview
and let's just grab the first one it
doesn't really matter and we can head
back over here and paste it in and if we
save this and head back over to the
website and hit reload you see okay
that's looking good it's asking for an
email address and a password and the
password has these dots in it that's
good it also has this check me out thing
we don't need that so we can get rid of
that as well also this is crammed right
up here I'm going to put a little space
in there so I think uh that will be
better so right here I just gonna add a
line break and all right let's start to
modify this thing so let's come down
here and first things first this button
is primary colored blue I want to change
it to secondary so if we save this come
back over here hit reload boom now it's
gray I think that looks better it says
submit maybe you want it to say log in
you could just change this to login
and now let's get rid of this checkbox
so check me out
click this div the closing div
highlights so we know we can delete all
of that
save it head back over here
all right that's gone the password field
is fine uh but uh this needs to be
changed from an email address field to a
text field
so we can do that let's see first let's
get rid of this label we don't need the
label for the password thing and get rid
of this div it says we'll never share
your email address we don't need that
and let's also get rid of this label
that says email address and instead of a
type of email this is going to be a type
of text
right and we have a class of form
control but we don't need an ID so let's
get rid of that
and same thing here with the password
field we don't need the ID thing so
we'll get rid of that okay so these two
things do need some things they need a
name so this one will give it a name of
first underscore name
and let's give it some placeholder text
and let's say first name
all right same thing down here with
password we need to give it a name so
I'm going to name it
you guessed it password
right and also let's give this some
placeholder text
and this is going to be password
so let's save this come back over here
and hit reload and oh that looks much
better we've got this placeholder test
text that says first name when we click
it and start typing that disappears uh
here we can still type the password and
that looks good when we click log in
nothing happens because you know we
haven't done anything yet we need these
to be required though so if you don't
fill them out we need a little thing
that pops up and says hey fill that out
so we could just come over here and then
just type in required
same thing for this guy required
and bootstrap will take care of this for
us so now when we hit reload
we don't need to resend this if I click
log in it says hey please fill out this
field so if I enter a name and then
click login it says hey please fill out
this field so that looks good it doesn't
actually go anywhere so
uh maybe we'll give a line break above
that button too so I don't know I like
line breaks I like to space things out
that's just me
uh resend okay so I don't know maybe
that looks better whatever you could
also put a line break between these two
things if you wanted
whatever
um let's see let's just do it right here
save this
reload
whatever whatever you like you can play
around with that so okay that looks good
but it doesn't actually do anything and
really we only want to show this if the
person hasn't already logged in so how
do we determine if a person has logged
in or not well we can come up here to
the top and we can say if user dot is
underscore
authenticated right then
let's say H1 hello world
right
else
do all this stuff and then down here at
the bottom
we
need to end our if statement so let's go
ahead and save this come back over here
now if we hit reload nothing changes
right but if I go to the admin section
and log in
right
now I'm logged in now if I go back to
the home page it just says hello world
and that form disappears so that's
pretty cool that works I'll go ahead and
log out again
now when I go back to the home page it
shows the login form again so okay we've
got this form it doesn't do anything yet
so probably need to work on fixing that
so let's head back over here and go to
reviews.pi file and inside of our home
view let's create some logic let's say
check to see if logging in so if a
person is logging in they are posting
otherwise they're just going to the web
page in which case they're getting
they're getting the request right other
than posting a request so we want to run
some logic let's say if request that's
this guy right here
dot method
equals
host
we want to do something right remember
this method here
on our home page we set this form method
to post right so we're posting the form
whenever we submit it and here it's
saying hey are they is this request
method a post if so hey they're filling
out the form let's do some form stuff
what do we need to do well let's grab
whatever they just submitted so let's
create a variable called username and we
can get whatever they typed into the
form by calling request dot post and
then passing in username
why username because on the form we gave
this field a name of oh first name we
should probably name this instead
username there we go
yeah brain freeze and instead of having
placeholder text say first name let's
have it say use her name that looks much
better save this let's head back over
here and refresh this okay so now it
says username and password I don't know
what I was thinking right so
add background reviews.pi file so our
username is going to equal username and
then we want our password to equal again
request dot post and then use our little
square Brack brackets and pass and
password again y password well because
on our home page here this password
field we gave it a name of password
right
right there so that's what we're looking
out for on the back end here these guys
right here and then we're just going to
assign whatever the person typed into
the form into this variable called
username we're also going to assign
whatever they pat whatever they typed in
as their password into this password
variable so now we have their username
and password we can run some logic and
say hey
is this a real user is their password
correct should we log them in and uh how
do we log them in so let's um you know
authenticate
and we do that by calling I'm just going
to create a variable called user and
then this will call the authenticate
function which is this guy up here that
we imported and inside of here we need
to pass in our request as always and
then set the username equal to username
which is this guy right here which is
whatever they typed in as their username
and we also need to pass in the password
as password which again is you know this
variable right here which is whatever
they typed in as their password so all
right that's pretty simple there so now
let's run some logic and see did they
type in everything does everything look
good let's go if user is not
none
then we want to log them in right so log
in
and then we want to pass in request and
user now if everything checks out here
if the username and password is correct
it gets passed in here and they'll be
logged in and let's create a message
right so let's go message.success and
then as always we pass in our request we
do that a lot and let's say you
have been logged in
I don't know that looks good and then we
want to redirect them somewhere well
where do we want to redirect them let's
just redirect them to the home page so
let's go return
redirect
and then home now we don't have the
ability to redirect yet so I'm going to
copy this and come up here to the very
top of the screen and we need to import
the redirect function there so okay that
looks good and we're good to go now we
can create an error message we could say
hey if something with went wrong and
they couldn't log in let's create a
message so
actually this should be message as there
we go so messages
dot success and we want to pass in our
request and let's say
there
was an error
logging in
please try again
I like the dot dot dots I don't know
it's just me and then I guess we
probably send them back home again right
so okay now we still have this guy down
here and the reason why that is is
because this is all set up to work if a
user is posting so if they're posting
process that else we can come back here
and we just want to send them to the
home page because if they're not posting
that means they're just going they're
just getting that page and in which case
we just want to show them the page so
let's go ahead and save this head back
over here and let's play around with
this first I'll hit reload and I'm going
to type in just nonsense here and click
login and we didn't get an error how
come well we actually need to add that
to our base.html file so if we come back
here to our base.html file
and underneath our nav bar but probably
still in our container let's create some
logic here let's say if messages so if
there are messages
and right away I'm going to end our if
because I forget to do that a lot of
times otherwise
right so then inside of here let's
display the message so
let's go for message in messages so it's
plural and then again I'm just going to
right away end my four
and inside of here we could just type in
the message for now so let's go ahead
and save this and let's see if that
worked so let's type in some nonsense
click this it says there was an error
logging in please try again there's an
air logging in please try again so this
doesn't look great we want to format
this so let's head back over to get
bootstrap and come down here to
components and click on alerts and
here's a little alert looks good we want
one with a little X in it so we can
close it so I'm just going to keep
scrolling down until I find one with an
X in it
oh there we go I'm just going to copy
this code head back over here and inside
of here I'm just going to paste all of
this in
tap it over to make it look nice
okay now we don't want it to say holy
guacamole so I'm gonna get rid of that
and instead of that we just want
to type in the message
right
that's this for message and messages
type out the message so all right let's
go ahead and save this try this again
head back over here
type in some nonsense
there is an error logging in please try
again
looking good
we can now try to log in with our actual
username
our admin guy and it says you've been
logged in and now it says hello world
very cool and that's all there is to it
we can now log in
okay so let's Now log out head back over
our code and the first thing we need to
do is head over to our urls.pi file and
uncomment out this log out thing I'm
going to leave this guy in here just in
case you want to create a separate login
page if you do you'll uncomment this out
and then you'll just come back over to
your views.pi file and create a log out
a login user function and basically just
put all this code in that function but
we're going to keep it the way it is and
do this all on the home page I think
it's a little more elegant doing it that
way so okay now let's create our log out
user function so this is actually very
simple a lot easier than logging in and
to do that we just call the log out
function
and then pass in our request now we can
do that log out function because up here
we imported this log out function that
will do all the work for us so that's
all we really need but we should
probably make this look nicer so let's
give this a little message so let's go
messages dot success that's in a request
and let's say I don't know what you have
been logged out dot dot love the dot dot
dots right and again we can just
probably redirect to the home page so I
can copy this guy
and then paste it down so all right
that's all we need now we need to
probably add a link to this in the nav
bar so let's head over to our nav bar
and here's this link now we only want
the logout link to appear if a user is
logged in if they're not logged in we
don't want them to be able to log out
they can't log out they're not logged in
right so that's actually pretty simple
to do let's just do some logic here
so let's go if user dot is underscore
auth
so that means hey if they are logged in
then let's allow them to log out
right else if they're not logged in and
let me just very quickly end my if so I
don't forget
and I'm going to copy this link and
let's create another link inside of here
so if they're not logged in we want them
to be able to log in all right so now we
need to point these somewhere so we need
a Django URL tag and we want this to
point to log out
there we go and let me just copy this
guy come down here and this one will
point to home because if they're not
logged in going to the home page will
show the login screen right so we want
to point them to the home all right
let's go and save this head back over to
the website and hit reload see if that
worked and we get a logout link when we
click it it says you've been logged out
and it redirects to the home login
screen and now we get this login link we
can try some nonsense that doesn't work
hey there was an error that's what we
want to see we still see this login link
if we log in
the login link changes to a log out link
and we're logged in and we can log out
and we can log in and it's good fun
all right so I'm gonna go ahead and log
out because now we need to register and
registering is a little bit more
complicated than logging in and we're
actually going to create a Django Forum
to handle that for us with logging in we
built the form ourselves by hand and
that's fine when it's basic like this
but the registration form is going to be
more complicated because we wanted to be
able to do a sort of logic type things
like if they type in a password that
doesn't follow the password rules you
know your password needs to be so long
it needs to have letters and numbers and
special characters and so we need to be
able to account for all of that we need
to be able to ask for a password twice
when you're registering so you enter it
once then you have to enter it a second
time to make sure the two match up so
that it's you know you've written it
correctly so that's a little bit more
complicated than a basic form like this
guy right here on the screen so we're
going to create a Django form for that
and it'll take care of it all for us so
there's gonna be a little bit of copying
and pasting because it's a lot of code
but I'll give you a link to my GitHub
where you can just copy and paste it
straight from there and that should be
piece of cake so let's get started doing
that
okay so a registration and I should
mention before we get going you may not
want to add registration right uh if you
don't want sort of open to the public
then leave this part off you can always
add users by coming into your admin
section here coming over clicking on
users and then clicking add users and
then manually entering them right here
pick a username have a password boom
you're done now you could do that if you
want to open this sort of company-wide
or whatever and you want people to be
able to sign up on their own at the
website then you need to do this next
little section so totally up to you
whatever you're interested in with your
project here but I'll give you both
methods here that way and this regular
registration method so let's head over
to our code and create a registration
page so let's hit up our urls.pi file
and I'm just going to copy this guy and
instead of log out let's call this
register
and it's going to be views dot register
underscore user and let's call this
register
all right that looks good save that
head over to our reviews.pi file and
let's define register underscore user
pass in our request as always
and then let's come up here and grab
this guy and paste him in but instead of
home.html let's call this register.html
and we're good to go there so I'm going
to copy this and head over to our
templates directory right click and
create a new file file save as and call
this register.html
and let's open up our home page and grab
this stuff
and paste it in
and let's say H1 register just for now
and let's go back to our home page and
grab this guy because why type it when
we can copy and paste it all right okay
all right so let's save this and add a
link to this page in our nav bar so if a
user is authenticated if they've logged
in we don't want them to be able to
register because they've already
registered so this should go in our else
block right here and let's just copy
this guy
and let's put it another one in first
and instead of it saying login let's
have it say register and we want to
point this to URL register all right go
ahead and save this head back over to
the website and let's see if that worked
we want to log out
when we're logged out we see there's a
register link we can click on it and go
to this page if we log in
that register link disappears okay and
we're good to go so let's log back out
again head over to our register page and
now we need to build out this page now I
mentioned before we're going to be
creating a Django form for this we're
not going to be hand coding this so that
would be both easier and harder so let's
come over here
to our website directory right click and
create new file file save as and we want
to save this as forms dot pi and in our
forms.pi file we need to import a few
things so let's go from django.contrib
dot auth dot forms we want to import the
user creation form
and you notice the U the C and the f are
all capitalized here and the user
creation Forum does just what it sounds
like it creates users right it does all
the work for us so we also want to go
from django.contrib
Dot auth
dot models we want to import the user
model and the user model is what we've
been using up until now it's what
allowed us to create our super user what
we've been logging in and logging out
with that admin user that all gets saved
to the user model right and that just
comes with Django it's already set up we
just have to import it and that should
be good enough so let's create a class
and I'm going to call this sign up form
and this is going to inherit the user
creation form and that's just this thing
we just imported right
so we're saying hey use that form but we
want to modify it a little bit right so
what we want is to grab let's say
people's first name their last name
their email address now you may not want
to grab their first name last name and
email address but I I suspect you
probably do just because it's good stuff
to have and this is how you do it so
let's define those things we want email
we want first underscore name and we
want last underscore name now we're also
going to want username and password but
we'll deal with those separately in a
minute so first here this is going to be
a
forms.email field
now this forms
we don't know what this is so we need to
import it so from up here we go from
Django we want to import forms
and that will allow us to use all these
forms so we've got an email field we
also want a forms.car field for this and
also a forms.car field or this guy as
well and car field stands for character
Fields so characters and a name letters
email is just email addresses it allows
Django to do regular email address stuff
like if you don't type in at symbol
Django will know because it's using this
email field and it'll throw up a little
error saying hey that doesn't look like
a real email address try again things
like that right so that's cool now each
of these
we're going to give a label of nothing
because we're gonna use placeholder text
so we don't want to actually text above
or below the fields so we can give that
to each of these next we want to give
this a widget
of forms dot text input
and that'll basically say hey the form
field that shows up on the screen that's
a text input field it's just a text box
basically right and inside of this we
want to give it adders attributes right
and this will allow us to pass different
attributes onto the page to style our
form so we're going to be using
bootstrap to style our forms and
bootstrap requires a class of form
control so we can designate that right
here so let's go class and then a colon
and then we can just type in form Dash
control and that's it now we also
probably want to pass some placeholder
text so again we can pass in placeholder
right here
and then designate whatever our
placeholder text should be and this
should just say email address
right so okay that looks good so now I'm
going to copy this
and we're going to paste that again in
right here
but we need to modify it a little bit
before our widget we need to give this a
Max underscore length of something
right so this looks like a capital l
right here it's not it's a lowercase L I
promise you anytime you see an L that
kind of looks swoopy like that in
Sublime Text same thing with this label
here this L there and that L and that L
those are all lowercase L's Sublime just
does that it makes it look weird like
that it confuses a lot of people they
think that's a capital l it's not it's a
lowercase L anyway we want to give this
a max length and I misspelled length
length there we go of I don't know say
100.
right
a person's first name shouldn't be more
than 100 characters long right you
should you could probably make it 50. it
doesn't really matter I'll just leave it
like that uh here again text input we
also want adders with form control for
the placeholder text here though we
should probably change this to first
name
that looks good
now I'm going to copy all of this and
paste it in again right there and this
one will say last name
okay that looks good so I know this is
all kind of scrunched up on the screen
maybe it's hard to read I'll give you a
link to all of this code uh in my GitHub
repository you can check that out after
this little section here we'll push our
code up to GitHub so that you can sort
of see it if you you know want to copy
and paste this stuff or look at it in a
web browser so okay that looks good
there now we also need to give this a
class with a meta of and we need to set
the model
so our model is going to be a user
because we imported that right up here
right we also need to designate the
fields in our form so they're obviously
going to have these three fields we also
want to designate username password one
and password two and remember we need
two sets of passwords so that we can
compare the two to make sure the user
isn't typing a typo or something it's
just a basic security precaution so here
we want to designate a username
we want to designate a first underscore
name we don't want to designate a last
underscore name
we want to designate an email address
and then we want to designate password
one and password two and Django
expects password 1 and password two so
you gotta have them both right so okay
that looks good
so we're halfway done now now we need to
copy and paste a few more things and I'm
just going to paste all this code in
and
the first thing I want to do is
tab all of this stuff over because
sometimes when you copy and paste the
tab gets a little out of control so you
want to make sure these have been all
tabbed properly so you can do it
manually each one like this and I'm just
using the tab button on my keyboard to
make sure that everything is tabbed
correctly even though it looks like it's
tabbed like it may
look like this see these dots that means
spaces have been used instead of tab
sometimes that happens when you copy and
paste things it doesn't look like it did
here but I just want to make sure so I'm
going to do that so what do we got here
well we are basically doing the exact
same thing we did here but we're doing
it down here for our username our
password one and our password two and
that just allows us to add whatever we
want in this case our adders our class
of form control as well as our label of
nothing so if you look through here
you'll see we've got username class
form control widget adders placeholder
right the label is nothing and also this
help text the help text is I mentioned
this a little while ago if you mess up
somewhere if you don't type the right
thing in a field this is the little help
text that will pop up and you know says
uh if we can look at here like the
password thing here it says hey your
password can't be
uh let's see let me pull this back your
passwords can't be too similar to the
other personal information your password
must contain at least eight eight
characters your password can't be too
commonly used password your password
can't be entirely numeric and these are
just different things that can pop up
and Django will pop them up as needed
but they have to be designated here just
to make them look good using bootstrap
right so like I said I'm just gonna
leave all this here you can copy and
paste it from my GitHub account we'll
look at that in just a minute I'll show
you where you can find that I don't want
to type all this stuff out it would take
forever and you don't either so you're
going to want to copy and paste this
this stuff here just initializes all of
this stuff it's basic python class stuff
these are double underscore so
underscore underscore right there's no
spaces here or here that messes up
people sometime and you'll notice we're
passing in the sign up form which is
this guy here this sort of allows us to
take all of this stuff and all of this
stuff and kind of mush them together and
output them onto the screen so okay I
think that looks good before we move
forward let me just push all this code
to GitHub and point you in the right
direction in case you want to copy and
paste this stuff which you probably will
let's head back over to our terminal hit
Ctrl C to break out of the terminal and
let me just add all this stuff to my
GitHub repository so get add period get
commit Dash am and let's just say
registration
we've done more than that but good
enough and then get push
all right now I'm going to turn our
server back on so that's running
now let's head over to github.com
forward slash flat planet and no I do
not think the world is flat I just find
it hilarious that some people do so
that's what my account is and you can
click on this Django CRM Link in
repositories or you could just go to
github.com forward slash flatplanet
forward slash Django Dash CRM the
capitalization is important so get that
right and then just click on website and
let's see forms.pi where is that
ah there it is
and here's all that code so you could
just you know copy it right out
right click copy paste it in boom you're
good to go so okay that's good now we've
got all this stuff we need to sort of
put it into the web page so let's head
back over to reviews.pi file and we need
to import that form that we just created
so let's come up here to the top and
let's go from dot forms we want to
import our sign up
form and it's sign up form because on
our forms.pi file here we named it sign
up form right there so notice the
capitalization capital S capital u
capital F that has to be the exact same
right here
so all right that looks good now we can
come down here to our register user View
and we start playing with this so like
with our login
right when somebody fills out this thing
they're going to be posting it so we
could just copy that right here if
request that method equals post then our
form is going to equal the sign up form
and we want to pass in the request dot
post
so we're basically saying hey whatever
they filled out in that form send it
over to our sign up form and do
something so what do we want to do well
first we need to figure out
is what they typed in valid right so
let's go if
form dot is underscore valid
and Django is doing all of this stuff
for us behind the scenes so we really
don't even care what most of this stuff
is so if it is if the form is valid then
we just want to save it so form dot save
and
what is the form that's this guy right
here which is our sign up form we just
want to save it right so now that the
form has been saved you know when
somebody fills out a registration form
they usually want to fill out the
registration form because they want to
use the site they want to log right in
and start using it so let's log them in
right now so let's uh authenticate
and log in so let's grab their username
and that's going to equal form dot
cleaned underscore data
and we want to pass in username this is
just
this form.clean data takes whatever they
posted on the form and pulls out the
username and assigns it to this username
variable we also want their password
so that's going to be form.cleaned
underscore data
and then password one right because on
the form on the website it will be
password one because let's see in our
forms.pi file
that's what it's called there right
so now once we have their username and
password we can try to authenticate them
so let's go user equals and again we
want to call authenticate and we want to
pass in the username equals username
and the password equals password
why password and not password one
because we took password one and we
assigned it to this variable called
password so that's what gets passed in
there
okay so once that's been done we can log
them in so let's log in we want to pass
in the request and we want to pass in
that user so if it was successful we
want to give them messages Dot
success
and we want to pass in the request and
let's say you have
successfully
registered
welcome whatever and then we want to
redirect them somewhere so let's go
return redirect and let's send them to
the home page right
so again this is if they're filling out
the form if they're posting the form if
they're not posting the form that means
they're just going to the website so
else now we still need that form
so let's set the form equal to our sign
up form you'll notice up here we passed
in the request here we're not passing in
the request because they haven't filled
out the form right they're just going to
the page they want to fill out the form
they haven't done it yet so we don't
have to pass in that post right right so
we do need to pass this form onto the
page so we could do that
inside of this
context dictionary so we put quotation
marks form colon form now notice this
has quotation marks this does not so
this will pass the form into the web
page our register.html page and then we
can do something with it right so let's
do something with it so let's head back
over to our register.html file and let's
add a little line break here and I'm
going to come back to our home page
where did that go there it is and let's
see I'm going to grab this guy so let's
come right up here and before I forget
let's close that div
and you know what we can also grab
this stuff as well
we'll grab that and we need to close our
form tag we also need a submit button so
let's grab this guy
go oh it looks like we've closed our
form tag twice we don't need that
all right uh back over here
boom
instead of it saying login let's have it
say register
okay and we also don't need that there
what is going on
we don't need two forms get rid of that
on the home page okay and that looks
good there head back over here all right
this looks good so we don't need to
point this to the home page we could
just take that out if we leave it out it
will post to itself so you don't really
need that so that's fine we need our
csrf token now we need to add the actual
form and to do that we just type
form dot as underscore P so if we save
this head back over here and hit reload
boom we get this very cool form now I'm
going to copy and paste some more code
here very quickly that you can find in
my GitHub account if you want it
but above this right below the csrf
token I can paste in if there are form
errors then this is a little div with an
alert it looks just like if we go over
to our base.html file there we go this
is the same code we grabbed from
bootstrap earlier it posts the messages
up on the screen right
uh back to our register page it just
does that same thing here and if there
are errors it says your form has errors
and then it Loops through here and it
puts out whatever error is on the form
right so that's kind of good to have
so I'll leave that in here you can copy
and paste it from my GitHub if you want
or you just leave it out it doesn't
really matter all that much but we're
good to go so if we come back over here
and hit reload we see we've got this
thing now if I click on this it says oh
you got to fill this out so let's give
this a try so let's create a username
I'm going to call this uh John and now
this is case sensitive so you'll have to
log in with capital j o h n in the
future so this is going to be John Elder
my email address is John
e4196 gmail.com my password is that and
if I click this again it says hey you
got to fill out that field now I'm just
going to type in garbage here so these
won't match and we get an error because
our views
uh head back to reviews.pi file and at
the beginning at the very end of our
registered user let's copy this and we
need to paste it in again so this will
that should take care of that let's save
this head back over here give this
another try
um now we get a little pop-up so I'm
going to type in my password let's try
this again gibberish here
now it says your form has error to
password field the two password Fields
don't match so that is
uh let's go back to
register.html that's this thing right
here in action so all right that looks
like that works that's pretty cool so
now let's actually register I'll type in
correct passwords here
click register boom you successfully
registered welcome and I can now log out
so let's now try and log in John
you have been logged in hello world now
if I log out and I go to my Dash admin
section and I log in as admin
and I click on users I'll see there's
John and there's admin
uh you'll notice admin is a staff user
he's got a little check mark John is not
John's just a regular user that signed
up on the website they can't log into
this section this admin section if
they're not a staff user thing so okay
very cool I'm gonna log out here head
back over here and we are good to go so
that is registration
and we'll notice if we log in again with
say John
our register link disappears our login
link disappears all we have is a link to
log out which is what we want or we can
go back to the home page which is again
what we want and we're good to go so all
right we are moving right along I think
the only thing left to do now is
actually set up the CRM stuff up until
now this has just been playing around
getting the website up and running we
want to now actually add in the ability
to save and view records to update them
to look at them to do all the fun things
and I think it's time and I'll start
doing that
so to set up database stuff the first
thing we need is a model so let's head
over to our models.pi file and this is
where we Define our model now like I
said earlier it really does not matter
what database you use the code here will
always be the same we're not writing SQL
code here we're not writing postgres
code here we're not writing sqlite 3
code here or MySQL code here this is
Django code it's just pure python that
creates a class that will then abstract
away and create that code for us on the
back end it will create the MySQL code
if you're using MySQL it will create the
postgres SQL code whatever database
you're using it will do it for you
behind the scenes and that's the great
thing about using Django so
um let's just dive in here and Define
our class so let's come down here and
let's create a class and what do we want
to call this I'm going to call this
record now you're going to say we're
saving records shouldn't it be records
no Django will pluralize it for us so
I'm going to call it record uh anything
you want if it's customers maybe you
would call it customer whatever and we
want to inherit model dot model
right and again this is a lowercase l so
is this which you know looks like
Capital but it's lowercase so now we
just Define the things we want so the
first thing I want is a created at field
and this is just going to add a little
time stamp for us so to do that we'll
call models
dot date time field and we just want to
set auto underscore now
underscore add and set that equal to
true so Django will just anytime we
create a new record it will just slap a
timestamp on there of when it was
created just automatically and keep
track of that for us if we ever want to
know when a record was created sort of
useful I always do that for almost every
model I ever create because even if
you're not going to use it you might
someday want to know when a record was
created and it's just a really easy way
to do it automatically so now let's
designate what we want to save we
definitely want to save a first name
we probably want a last name
let's go address
and then City
state
zip code
you know whatever you want if you wanted
their email you could do email
leave that off
um
if you wanted well let's let's put it on
let's be crazy email equals and phone
equals and maybe we'll put
these two up higher right after last
name maybe so we've got a fair amount of
stuff here right so what do we do now
well we need to designate what these are
going to be so this is going to be a
models.car field and again that stands
for character field and we want to set
the max underscore length
to I don't know what's let's say 50
right so I'm just going to copy this and
again this is a lowercase L I know it
looks Capital but uh it's not so let me
just pop all of this stuff in here now
we can change these Max lengths for
instance maybe your email address might
be a little bigger put that at 100 it
really shouldn't be uh a phone number is
like area code three digit code
and maybe there's a one so I mean I
don't know that at 15 or something that
should be fine your address I don't know
maybe 100 City characters are never
longer than 50 state is more like
probably what
yeah 50 unless you're doing like
abbreviations like NV for Nevada IL for
Illinois but ah we'll leave it at 50.
and the zip code I don't know let's put
that at 20. now some people want to do
like number fields for zip codes but I
leave it at care as car field because
you're never going to do math on a zip
code even though a zip code is a number
in some countries zip codes have letters
in them too right so I don't know in
Canada I think it's like 26 H 597 or
something you know same thing in grade
Britain a lot of countries use uh
letters in zip code so we're gonna leave
that as car field so that's pretty much
it now we can Define
underscore underscore Str underscore
underscore pass in ourself
and then here we can just return
what we want to show on the screen if we
just access one of these records so I'm
going to create an F string
and inside of here I'm going to pass
self DOT first
underscore name
and we'll do it again and we'll go self
dot last underscore name so if you just
call one of these records
in the admin area or on a web page it
will return the first name and the last
name right so that's good that's a good
enough representation for us for now and
uh that should be good so go ahead and
save this and this is it this is all you
have to do to create a database model in
Django you don't need to know any SQL
Django will take this and convert it
into the SQL but to do that we need to
make a migration and push that migration
into the database and we did a migration
way back at the beginning of this course
because Django by default has some
database stuff that needs to be pushed
into the server into the database
migrated into the database and we did
that using the migrate command watch
back to the beginning of this video to
see that again we need to do that again
but first we need to make a migration so
let's head back over to our terminal and
we're getting oh we got an error it
looks like here on line four which uh
yeah this should be
models.model right here
is up here at the top we're importing
models so models.model save that that
looks good always nice to check in with
the terminal before we get going and
okay it looks good now now Ctrl C to
break out of our server and let's create
a migration let's go python manage.pi
make migrations and this is plural we're
making one migration but the command is
still migrations uh so keep that in mind
hit enter and boom it's created a
migration and we can look at this
migration if we want it's zero zero one
underscore initial dot pi and it's in
our migrations folder so if we head back
over here and here's our migrations
folder if we open it boom yeah sure
enough there it is here's our migration
and this is what Django has done it's
taken the stuff from our models.pi file
all of this stuff and it's created
a migration
and you'll notice here's our created at
first name last name email phone address
city state ZIP it's also given us an ID
now this is very useful Django does this
automatically as well it assigns a
primary key to each record so it will
take care of all that for us we don't
need to Auto increment anything we don't
need to designate something as the
primary key that's what this ID field is
and you'll see it kind of tab over here
it's set as the primary key right so
that's really cool and that's pretty
much it this is our migration so now we
have this migration we need to push it
into the database into our mySQL
database and we do that on the terminal
we just go python
manage that pie migrate
which we did this command earlier at the
beginning of the video with that initial
migration and boom it's done so you
could probably look at this in the MySQL
workbench
if you want you can come over here to
elderco and click refresh
and you'll see
website record
now exist in our table
right
and if we click on it we see it has the
created at first name last name email
phone address city state and zip code
very cool boom done right that's all
there is to it so very very cool and we
can now start using this thing and
to do that let's head over here to our
admin section and log in there just to
see and oh gotta turn server back on
so python manage.pi run server
okay now when we head back over here hit
reload we can log into the admin section
and you would expect to see that new
records model listed here but it's not
we have to actually add it so we can do
that really easily just come over here
let me close this migrations folder and
we want in Min dot pi and from here we
just need to import that model that we
created so let's go from dot models
import record
right and that's because our models.pi
file we called that record right so from
dot models models.pi import this record
right there we go and then we need to
register this on the admin section of
the site so we just go admin Dot site
dot register and pass in that record
save this head back over to the website
hit reload and boom now our records pops
up and you'll notice it's records it's
pluralized it like I said it would and
so if you named it records when you
created the model it would be records
with two s's right
which is weird but that's why we only
put it as record in the model when we
created it so we can click on this guy
and you can see there's no records right
now I just want to manually add a couple
so we have something to work with pretty
soon here we'll create a form on the
website where you can add them there but
for now I'm just going to create a
couple so let's say first name John
Elder say John at elder.com that's not
real one on one two two two three three
three three my address says 10 West
Elder Street uh Las Vegas
Nevada
89137 we can click save and boom there
it is so if we go back to this main
thing click on records again there's
John Elder very cool so let's add
another one just we'll just add two for
good measure and this is going to be
Mary Smith
her name her email is Mary at smith.com
her phone is six seven seven seven seven
six six six five five ah whatever her
address is uh 27 Mary way right in
Chicago Illinois 60610
whatever fake data and there's Mary
Smith
so very cool
now we want to be able to view these
things from the website so let's head
back over to the website I'm still
logged in as admin and we want these to
show up on the home page when a person
is logged in we don't want this stuff to
show up if they're not logged in but if
they are we want to show up there so
let's head over to our code and start to
build this all out so let's go to
reviews.pi file and let's play around in
our home view right here so let's well
first we need to import that model up
here at the top so let's go from dot
models we want to import record
right so right at the top of our home
view let's grab all of the records that
are in the table right now so I'm going
to create a variable called records
and this is going to be a record
dot objects
dot all so this will just grab
everything in the table and assign it to
this records variable now we can pass
that in to our web page right so let me
copy this and let's come down here
this stuff is still if a user is posting
We don't want to mess with that but if
they're not posting the form to log in
it means they've already logged in and
we want to view the page so here we'll
just pass in records colon records
all right so let's go ahead and save
that and now let's head over to our
home.html file where'd that go there it
is
and we've already got this set up to
where if they're authenticated we want
to say hello world instead of that let's
say uh Records for now we'll probably
get rid of that but for now let's just
say that
and let's run some logic
so let's go if records
if there are records we want to do
something and right away I want to end
my if so I don't forget now what do we
want to do well
we likely have lots of Records we're
pulling everything out of the database
there's probably more than one right we
would expect so let's Loop through them
all and put them on the screen so let's
say for record in records
and again right away I'm gonna end my
four because if I don't I'll forget now
where's this records coming from well
that's just this thing right here that
we passed onto the screen which is
actually
this thing which is all of the records
from the database table right that we
just created from our model so okay so
for record and Records let's just print
out
the record
and we can
give a little line break here
between each one
and okay so let's
see what this looks like so let's hit
reload and we see John Elder and Mary
Smith why is it only putting John Elder
and Mary Smith where's the rest of the
stuff well you'll remember right back
here where we defined our model that's
this stuff right here we've told it only
to return first name and last name if we
just call the record so if we call a
record it's going to return first name
and last name all the rest of the stuff
is in there it's all packed in there we
just have to pull it out explicitly if
we want which is what we want to do
right you don't want to spill out
everything like this so to grab each
specific item we would call record dot
whatever so record DOT first underscore
name
and
let me just come through here and make a
few of these so this would be a record
dot last name
and I'm just gonna paste a bunch of them
in here and just look at our model these
are the things so next is email
let me close some of these so
this will be a record email then we want
phone
probably and you could put these in any
order but I'm just gonna go through and
put them in the order we have them here
uh let's see this is gonna be address
then City this is very exciting work and
copy paste copy paste City
state
and finally zip code
we could also do
let's see what else we have we also have
created at we can output that if you're
curious to see what that is we also have
an ID because Django automatically
creates an ID so let's go ahead and save
this and see now I put these on multiple
lines but in reality the HTML is going
to print it all out on one line
and we see sure enough there it is John
Elder John elder.com
Mary Smith same deal so this is hard to
read
even with a couple extra line breaks
here
still hard to read what we really want
here is a table that you know looks nice
and we can click on and do things so
let's look at that
and to do that we're gonna head back
over to bootstrap and bootstrap has
something called tables and I'm just
gonna search for table there it is it's
in the content section so click on
tables
and here are all the different table
options so to create a table in
bootstrap we just need to copy this
stuff so I'm going to copy
let's see actually let's grab all of
this so we want the table we want the
head which is this first row and each of
these things are each of these columns
and then we want a table body and a TR
so that looks good we're gonna have to
Tinker with this so let's go right here
and paste all this in
there we go uh we also need to close all
those things so let's come down here to
the bottom and grab those closing tags
and we'll just paste all that in
okay
maybe tap that over
so this is our table head and so the
first thing is going to be name
and we'll smush the first and last name
together for one name and then after
that it's going to be email
then phone
then address and we're going to need a
few of these so
after address is City
then state
and zip code
then we probably want the created at
maybe
and then ID
so let's save this and just refresh to
see if that looks okay
and we're getting smooshed in here so
we'll we'll have to play around with
this a little bit
for instance I guess we don't really
need this offset
centered thing so I'll take I'll take
that out
and that out
so now okay stretching all across that
looks better the name email phone
address city state ZIP code created at
an ID all right and I think we can take
credit I think we need to take out that
records thing for now
it's just annoying
okay so now we need to
put all of this stuff
inside this table so I'm just going to
grab all of this copy it and paste it
right in there
and this TR
I'm going to copy this it stands for
table row so
that will go here
have all that over and then let's close
the table row so we can get rid of that
one there
so for each record it will Loop through
here and create a new row a
table row with each of these things now
the actual columns we designate those
with TD tags and
closing TD tags so again I mentioned we
want a first name and last name in the
same column
right I think that makes sense
and then for the rest of these we just
give them a TD so I'm going to copy and
paste
like that very quick and then same thing
here we want to close our TD tag oh let
me just sort of
paste this in
that's pretty fast I got skills
okay so let's go ahead and save this and
refresh and see if that all matches up
and okay looks like it does name John
Elder notice how we put both the first
name and the last name in the name
category you could have a you could have
a column for a first and a column for
last name if you want I don't know I
think this looks better
uh name email phone address I'm just
checking to make sure everything lines
up looks like it does okay so we're good
to go so now we want to modify this
because this does not look great right
so uh bootstrap has all kinds of cool
things you could do so just come through
here and look and see what you like now
striped Rose I like that that looks
pretty good so to add that we just add
this table striped class to our our main
table class so if we come back up here
and go to the top here's our main table
class we just inside these quotes add
table striped save this and back over
here hit reload and okay now they're
striped we only have two records so
there's only two stripes but you can
imagine it looks better uh what else we
got uh let's come through here
different types of stripe uh hoverable
so when when you go over it's it hovers
I think that's cool let's do it up so we
just copy this table Dash hover
and again we just paste it into the same
spot we give a little
space there and paste it in space and
paste all right so let's come back over
here hit reload now when we hover
it changes color very cool what else we
got here
active tables no we don't need that
uh what else table borders I like
borders
because otherwise
it looks incomplete to me so let's add a
border again
space and paste I'm going to run that
into the ground catchphrase
all right so now we've got that okay
that looks better
what else
we could make it into a small table
right giving it a table SM command I
don't know that I want to do that but
let's take a look space and paste
I'm easily amused if you didn't figure
that out so if you hit reload boom it
just scrunched together I do not like
how that looks so we're gonna take that
out
save that come back over here hit reload
much better I like space space is good
uh you can have dividers man
vertical alignment
whatever you like play around with all
this stuff
we can change the color of the head too
dark I like that to do that we give a we
give our table head tag this class
so let's copy this
and find our table head tag
and there it is so space and paste
save it and back over here
reload and yeah I like that that looks
good
and now we're moving right along so yeah
that was pretty easy so now we need a
few different things right we need the
ability to add a record on the web page
we also need to and the ability to click
on one of these and go somewhere and
view the record on its own we can do
that we also want to edit those records
probably when we click on them and view
them as their own on their own so we
need to do all of those things so that
is up next
so yeah let's make this ID clickable so
when we click on it you could do the
same thing for the first name if you
want have it clickable and then let's go
to a separate web page where we can view
just that record right so let's head
back over to our code hit our urls.pi
file we need a URL for that so I'm just
going to copy this last guy here and
let's call This Record because we want
to look at specific records and now we
want to pass something we want to pass
an integer as a primary key right and
you'll see what this is in just a second
we want to point this to views dot let's
call this
I don't know customer underscore record
and let's point this to record
go ahead and save that now head back
over to reviews.pi and let's come down
here and let's define customer
underscore record
we want to pass in the request
we also want to pass in that primary key
what primary key well if we go back to
our urls.pi file
that's this thing right here right so
this will essentially look like uh you
know localhost
colon 8000 forward slash record forward
slash two right and the reason why is
because that two
will be the primary key it will pass
into the view it'll come in here then
we'll take that to or whatever and we'll
pump it into the database and say hey
return record number two right so we
know
for instance that Mary Smith is two and
then Django will return Mary Smith's
record so that's just a very quick and
easy and normal way to look up specific
records from a web page so let's head
back over here
and let's build this guy out so we
probably don't want everybody in the
world viewing these records you we
probably only want you to be able to see
them if you're logged in so we can check
right here if you're logged in or not so
we could go if request
dot user
dot is underscore authenticated
then let's look up that record so look
up record
how do we do that well I'm going to
create a variable called customer
underscore record
and we're going to set that equal to
record
dot objects
dot get and we want the ID to equal PK
which is that number they got passed in
with our request right and the ID of
course is the ID from our migration
this guy right it's our primary key
right they're unique everybody's record
has a unique primary key so you'll
notice this lookup thing here if we come
back here
to our home page we we looked up
record.objects.all to get all of the
objects to get a single object we call
record.objects.get and then pass in the
ID that we want to get and then it will
take that record and assign it to this
variable that we can then pass on to the
web page and view on the web page in the
same manner we've done other things like
that like here and here all right so let
me grab this guy and just copy it and
paste it underneath here instead of
going to register.html we want to
probably go to what record
that HTML and instead of passing form we
want to pass the customer record
so boom
and boom
okay
now
that's if the user is authenticated if
they're not then let's create a little
message and I'm just going to come up
here to one of these other messages
and copy them paste them in
make sure the tab correct they're tabbed
correctly and let's throw up a little
message that says you
must be logged in to view that page
and then we'll redirect them to the home
page
so okay let's go ahead and save this now
we need a record.html page so I'm going
to copy this remember Django is always a
three-step process when you're creating
something you need a URL you need a view
and you need the page so this is the
view we already did the URL now we just
need the page head over to templates
right click new file file save as and we
want to save this as record.html or
record.html
and then let's grab our
maybe our register page I just want to
copy these things here
very quickly our block tags
foreign
let's just say uh
customer record
for now we'll change this in a second I
just want to make sure this works for
now
and there we go so let's give this a try
so let's head back over here and let's
go to record slash one and what we do it
says customer record good now if we're
logged out and we go to
record slash one
it says You must be logged into the Via
this page and it sends us back to the
home page all right
so let's log in here
now we want to make these clickable with
a link so how do we do that so let's
head back over here to our home
and I've noticed that the login screen
was different so let's go back to our
register page and let's grab this div we
took it off a bit ago so this entire
table would fit but down here in the
login we probably want to put it back so
let's save this now let's just test that
real quick log out okay now it's
centered again
but likewise this one is allowed to
stretch out so okay that's what we want
so now let's add these links right here
so head back over to the home page
and for the ID you could do it like I
said on the first name last name but I'm
going to do it just for the ID
the process is the same let's go H or f
equals
like that and then we want to close our
H our a tag and then here we create a
Django link URL tag and we want to pass
this to a record
but we also want to pass in the record
dot ID
so if we save this head back over here
hit reload now we have these links if
you hover though so look down here in
the corner down in the bottom left hand
corner it says record four slash one if
I go to this one it says record forward
slash two that's what
this thing here does it puts the ID
which we know is this guy right here
into this link so okay let's go try that
let me reload it again and let's click
on this and boom customer record all
right now it goes to record slash one
and record slash two but there's nothing
showing up on those pages right now so
we need to change that so back to our
views.pi file and
let's see here is where we're passing in
the customer record we have the customer
record we can access it on the page so
let's copy this and let's head back over
to our record.html and here I can just
pop in the customer record
so if I save this
head back over here hit reload we get
Mary Smith
come back again click one we get John
Elder now again it's the same deal it's
it's putting out the default thing we
can break it down into into everything
in the record if we want so let's go
ahead and do that so I'm going to go
back over to our home page and we're
going to do some copying and pasting
here
as we want all of this stuff
so
let's go back to our records page and
instead of that let's pop this in
um
we need to we could take out all of
these things
very quickly here
not as fast as deleting as I am as
copying and pasting
[Music]
very exciting work here
okay so again we probably want little
spaces here because this is all going to
be on one line until we fix it we don't
want a URL here so we'll take out this
link
as well okay so let's just save this and
see what we got here
hit reload oh
everything is gone wonky
oh this should be customer underscore
record obviously
oh let me just paste paste paste paste
paste and paste okay save this head back
over here now that should work and boom
we get all of John Elder's stuff
scrunched onto the screen so all right
that's not great we need to want to
format this a little bit so let me just
move this over make it look nicer and we
can start out by adding some line breaks
so let me copy this
there we go save this head back over
here
all right that's looking a little bit
better not a whole lot better but uh
let's see we're missing a first name and
last name here
oh I forgot to
add
this this is what happens when you copy
and paste
all right let me there we go that's
easier to read so now
all right so
okay that's not great let's make this
look nicer so let's head back over to
bootstrap we always go to bootstrap when
we want to make things look nicer and
head down to components and let's grab a
card so I'm just going to scroll through
here until something catches my eye
and uh oh this looks good let's grab
this so I'm going to copy this head back
over here
and
let's get rid of customer records and
let's paste in this card so if we save
this head back over here and just look
and see what we have we got this nice
looking card that looks pretty good
where it says featured let's put the
name all right
I think that'll look professional so I
can just get rid of this BR and copy
this first and last name and let's just
boom pop them right in there so
let's save this head back over here see
how that looks
that says John Alder there very cool
let's get rid of this button here we
don't need that
so that's this guy right here
get rid of that save it
reload it all right that looks better
and then maybe right here where it's a
special title treatment that's where
we'll put everything else and we'll get
rid of this one here so
ah that would be this
otherwise it's going to be card title H5
for everything in our list here so maybe
we want that maybe we don't
for now
let me get rid of all these br's
there we go and we could just copy all
of this stuff Ctrl C to copy or right
click and copy and right here
I'm just gonna paste all these things in
so I'm a little I'm a little torn we
could
do like this
for each one of these
so
like that
you know on and on let's save this and
see what this looks like
all right so if the size of the text is
what you want I don't really like that
size of that text so let's change this
out instead of using the chord title H1
let's use this p uh class card text I
think that probably will be better so
let me just copy this and here we'll
just do it like this we'll get rid of
this
and this
and all of these things
all right
and instead of H5 tag this will be a
closing P tag now
actually we do now I'll need all of
those line breaks that we deleted
so I don't know play around with this
make it look however you want I'm bad at
design stuff
uh but uh that should work let's take a
look at this and
and we don't need the John Elder because
it's already there so see we'll take
that out
there we go
so maybe that's good enough maybe you
want to put the email phone City like
the words in front of them maybe
something like that so let's go strong
strong
let me copy this for each of these guys
and inside of here maybe we type in like
email
and then
phone
and this is becoming unruly address
though you probably want to put some
spaces around here so City
all right
state
zip code
created at
and finally
ID
something like that again this is
beginning to be ridiculously hard to
read so I'm going to put some spaces
after the br's
so at least it's a little bit easier to
designate what's what here so all right
go ahead and save this or you could just
kinda
see
highlight all of this stuff and tab it
over a few times
it makes it a little easier to read
whatever good enough let's head back
over to the page and hit reload and ah
there we go like that I don't know it
still seems a little scrunched together
to me so instead maybe we do a P tag for
each thing and instead of a br let's get
rid of those again
we do something like this
let me save this and reload it see
yeah that puts some space in between
each item maybe that's what you like
whatever you like
I think maybe I'll do that real quick
here
just add
peas
each of these guys
and then
like that
there we go get rid of this one
and this is not very exciting
television is it
or YouTube division
okay so save this
we could Tinker with this all day and
that looks good whatever and here John
Elder maybe you want to make that bold I
don't know let's go strong
strong I don't know we're just playing
around at this point
whatever whatever you like uh it's
totally up to you like that and uh yeah
looking good so we might want a back
button down here below
so let's go test save this
make sure we're in the right spot yep
there it is
so we definitely want line breaker 2
there and we can create a little
button here we can go href equals
and this is going to be a Django URL tag
you want to send it back to what the
home page probably
right
and then here we can have it say back
and then inside of here we can make it a
button by giving it a class equals BTN
space BTN Dash let's say secondary
something like that that will make a
gray button so if we hit reload we've
got this back button now will we go to
Mary she's got a back button
very cool so okay step one put the thing
on the screen step two maybe we want to
delete so we want to delete button right
so let's come back over here let's grab
this guy
and right next to him let's put a
let's say delete button instead of
button secondary let's put button danger
that will make it red and scary
so there we go now it says delete we
click delete it goes back it doesn't
actually delete yet we're gonna have to
build that functionality in and um let's
go ahead and do that now so all right
what are we doing here we're doing a
thing in Django things in Django are
always three-step processes you need a
URL you need a view and you need the
thing in this case we don't need the
thing we're not sending them to a delete
page we're just doing an action so
actually we need two things this time
but we can start to do that head over to
urls.pi file and let's copy this guy and
paste it in and let's Create A New Path
a new URL and instead of calling This
Record I'm going to call it delete
underscore record again we still want to
pass this primary key because we need to
know which record to delete right so
that makes sense and here instead of
customer record let's call delete record
and for the name again let's call delete
underscore record oh okay that looks
good
save that head back over to reviews.pi
file and let's create a new view
so Define delete underscore customer
pass in our request we also want to pass
in that primary key so we know which
record to delete very important and
deleting records is pretty easy sort of
like logging out there's not much to it
so I'm going to create a variable called
delete it all right and this is going to
be a record dot objects
dot get just like when we looked it up
earlier we still just want to pass in
the ID of primary key right that will
get the record that we want to delete
now we just delete it so we call delete
underscore it dot delete
and that's it so again just like earlier
when we're logging in and logging out we
probably want to
flash up a little message or something
right
so
let's say
record
deleted
successfully dot dot dot and we probably
want to send them back to the home page
now anybody can do this so we probably
want to say only do this if the person
is logged in right so let's grab all of
this
else let's say
again
you must be logged in to do that
thing to do that I don't know whatever
and pass them to the home page all right
let's go ahead and save this and see if
that worked I'd be very very sad to see
Mary Smith go but
in the name of science uh oh we've got a
we've got an error
at our terminal uh oh delete record I
did not save ah we called this delete
customer
what did we call in our urls.pi delete
record so that's the problem
Elite record there we go save this now
if we head back over here and hit reload
there we go so like I said Mary Smith's
gotta go click Mary Smith click delete
and that did not work because we didn't
update our button here so all right
let's head back over here to our
record.html come down here to our delete
button and this needs to go to I've
already forgotten again what we've
called it delete record so the name of
this is delete record
copy this add back over here and instead
of pointing this to the home page we
need to point it to delete record and
again we need to pass our customer
underscore record
dot ID all right so go ahead and save
this Mary is just sticking around didn't
she now when we hover over here you see
down at the bottom it says delete
underscore record forward slash two so
let's start over let's click here boom
two Mary Smith
nice knowing you record deleted it
successfully oh it says records deleted
let's change that
so
record there we go all right not bad and
that was pretty easy so all right so
moving right along we can see all of our
records on the home page we can click on
each individual one see them
individually that looks decent and we
can delete them or go back now let's add
records
so let's head over urls.pi file
and I'm gonna grab
one of these and let's call add
underscore record
and this is going to be views Dot
add underscore record
and here the name we'll call it add
underscore record
so that looks good
I'm gonna go ahead and copy this and
let's head back to our views.pi file and
let's create a new view so let's define
add record we pass in our request as
always
and let's see let's come up here and
grab one of these guys here
come down here paste it in so again
we're going to point this to add
underscore record dot HTML we haven't
created that yet so let's do that we
don't need to pass anything in just yet
we might later we'll see go ahead and
save this now head over to
templates right click new file file save
as and we want to save this as
add underscore record dot HTML
and again let's head over to our record
page
and grab
these basic things and let's say H1 add
record
and head back over here again grab the
end block
paste that in okay that looks good now
let's add a link to this in the nav bar
so let's head over to our template slash
navbar
and we probably only want to see this if
a user is logged in right so that's
going to be in our is authenticated
block right
so let's say right here let's give this
a link to add record
and we want to point this to add
underscore record
save it and back over here hit reload
now we have this add record link well I
click it it goes to this add record page
and uh yeah looking good so all right
let's build out this add record page
it's getting exciting so let's head back
over here I'm gonna go to my home page
and come down here
and grab this centering thing that we've
been playing with in the past
and let's add a little line break and
let's also go back here and grab our
form stuff here
so grab this
and what else we need this closing stuff
and a button so we'll just copy this as
we go along this gets easier because we
can just reuse code that we've already
played with in the past so here let's
have it say add record and instead of
pointing it to home we want to point it
to add underscore record
okay that looks good and let's just
create a form for this so let's go form
dot as underscore p and like I said
we're going to create a Django form for
this
so all right that looks good so now
let's head back over here and let's go
to our forms dot Pi file and let's build
out this form so here's our sign up form
we could just come down here below it
and create
add record form so let's create a class
and I'm going to call it add record
form and this is going to inherit forms
dot model form
like that now we don't have to import
model form because we've already
imported forms so up here we from Django
import forms that will allow us to use
the model form and a model form is just
what it sounds like it takes a form and
adds it to the model our model is the
record model so we need to import that
so let's go from dot models
we want to import record
and now we can use that on this page so
let's come down here and build this guy
out so we want a first underscore name
we want our last underscore name
we want well basically all the things
from our model dot Pi file so first name
last name created at we don't need that
because Django does that for us but we
need email phone and address so
let's go email
phone and address what else we got
city state ZIP code
so City
State and zip code
we also don't need the ID Django will
create that for us so up here let's
create one let's go forms dot car field
it's almost always a car field right
and we probably want to set required
equal to true for all of these because
we want
info for every one of these we don't
want people to be allowed to leave
anything blank right so okay so like
earlier we need to set a widget and this
is going to be forms.widgets
dot text input
and again we need our adders
curly brackets and here let's give this
a place holder text
of first name
and we also want to give this a class
of form Dash control for the
bootstrapifying make it look nice with
bootstrap
and then outside of here let's also
create a label and set it equal to
nothing now again this is a lowercase L
both of these are I know they look like
they're not but they are
and that looks good so I'm just gonna
copy all of this stuff
and let's paste it in for each one of
these
okay but this is going to be last name
this is gonna be email
this is gonna be I think phone
let's make sure yep that looks good
address city state ZIP code
so address
City
state
and zip code
okay that looks good so I know this is
kind of hard to read again you can look
at it on my GitHub page if you need to
now we also need to set our class of
meta and designate what model we want to
use so model equals is going to be our
record model we also can either
designate the fields or we could just
say exclude and set it equal to our user
and a comma and that will just add all
the fields so that's an easier way to do
it sometimes you can get away with doing
it that way and in this case we can so
okay let's go ahead and save this so we
have this add record form let's now
import that to our views.pi file so up
here at the top we want from forms
import signup form and add record form
so now we can use this in our view so
let's do that down here to our add
record View and let's designate a form
and this is going to be our add record
form and let's go request dot post or
none so this will allow us to say hey
are they posting the form are they
adding a record if not just go to the
web page so that's a second way to do
that we did it a little bit differently
earlier but I like to show you different
ways to do the same things in case
something is better suited to whatever
you happen to be working on so let's go
if request
dot user dot is underscore authenticated
if they're logged in then let's allow
them to post so let's say hey if request
dot method
equals
host
then again from earlier we need we know
we need to say hey is this thing valid
so let's go if form dot is underscore
valid
then what well let's add underscore
record equals form dot save
and again unless messages dot success
SNR request
and let's say I don't know record added
that whatever and then let's return
redirect
to the homepage
okay
otherwise if they're not posting
then we just want to well
do this guy
make sure this lines up with this if
statement for the Post right
but we want to pass in the form so form
colon form because we want that form to
show up on the page if they're not
filling out the form it means they want
to fill out the form so we need to pass
the form onto the page right
all right else so if they're
authenticated do all this stuff
otherwise they're not authenticated so
we need to send them a little message
uh let's just copy this
right and let's just say what
you must be logged in whatever
okay so let's go ahead and save this and
that should do it let's try this out so
let's go add record and we've got this
nice form now I'm going to copy this
link and let's log out
now let's go to that page ah you must be
logged in that works so let's log us in
now we can add a record and let's bring
Mary Smith back man she was she was
something right Marriott mary.com Mary's
phone is 555
that's not six she lived at 10 Mary way
in Maryville
Illinois
with that zip code all right fingers
crossed add record boom record added
there she is
and now her ID is three because it's
incremental right the last one was two
we deleted that the next one will be
three that's how primary Keys work and
we're good to go so we are moving right
along we can add records
right
we can log out we can log in
we can register now all we need is the
ability to update our record
so let's come through here head back
over to our record page
and where did that go right there and
let's grab this now let's grab this link
here
and let's say what
update record
and let's pass this to update underscore
record
so now we need to create this guy
all right so save this head over to our
urls.pi file and I'm going to copy this
delete guy because you guessed it we're
going to have to pass the primary key
again because we need to know which
record to update right so here instead
of delete record this will be update
record and this will point to our update
record View
and let's call this guy
update record okay so save that head
over to reviews.pi file
and let's define update underscore
record
we want to pass in our request as always
and also that primary key because we
need to like I said look up which record
to update and we only want to allow this
if somebody's logged in as always so I'm
just going to copy this guy
and if the request.user.is authenticated
what do we want to do well let's grab
our current record
right
and this is just going to be the same
thing we've done before
let's just grab this
so this is going to be
record.objects.get
the ID of whatever that primary key is
assign that record to this current
record and now we can play with it so we
can use this ad record form so I'm going
to just grab this whole thing
copy it and paste it
now
what we want is when somebody goes to
this page and this form pops up we want
it to be already what's the word
propagated with whatever the record is
and we can do that by just passing right
here where it says or none
we could just give this an instance
of the current underscore record
and we've defined what that current
underscore record is right here it's the
record with the primary key that we
passed into the page right we've grabbed
that record we can pass it back to the
page in an instance of it just like that
so very very cool and uh actually pretty
simple so now we've done hey are they
posting or are they doing nothing if
they're doing nothing it means they want
to post they're going to change
something and then resubmit it otherwise
they're going to post so if they have
posted right so let's go if
form
dot is underscore valid we've seen this
before
we just want to form dot save the guy
right and then let's throw up a little
message
because we're marrying and helpful
people right and let's say
record
has been updated
and we just probably want to redirect to
the home page
all right otherwise
let's just show them to the page so
let's come down here and paste this guy
in and instead of add record
this is going to be update record
and we still definitely want to pass in
that form right which is this guy else
so if they're authenticated do all this
otherwise let's throw up a message let's
just copy this guy right here
you must be logged in redirect them back
to the home page okay so now we need
this updaterecord.html page it's easy to
forget about that guy but let's go ahead
and save this and head over to our
templates right click new file file save
as update underscore record.html
and again let's just kind of grab some
stuff here actually let's grab all of
this stuff we're probably gonna need it
so ah we don't even need this let's get
rid of this action let's streamline this
stuff csrf token form as p
uh add record let's change the button to
say update record yeah pretty much
everything is going to be the same
uh we have this guy here we never really
close that div tag which means we
probably didn't over here either in our
ad record
that's just bad form
still works still valid it's just not
good form so okay uh update record that
looks good so
now if we head back over to the web page
we need to fix our button here so this
is on the regular record page so let's
go to our record at HTML and down here
we created this update record but we
need to pass the customer underscore
record
dot ID so we know which one to update
right obviously let's go come back over
here create some reloads all right so
Mary Smith
here she is we want to update her boom
here is the form it's already filled out
with Mary Smith's stuff which is awesome
notice there's no field for ID we don't
want to be able to change the ID that's
the primary key you can't change that
and you also don't want to be able to
change the created at field because
that's no good either you can add an
updated at field if you wanted to I'll
leave that to you same principles as the
created at field you just you know
Tinker around and add it here but let's
change Mary to Mary to update record
record has been updated it says Mary to
Smith and that seems to have worked
if you come back here we want to change
it back
get rid of that update record boom
record has been updated and we are good
to go I think that's it I think we are
done right has everything you would want
to do we can register we can log in we
can log out we can see all the records
we can add a new record
we can
maybe we want to put a button here that
says back
I don't know if we click we can click on
an individual record to view it we can
delete it we can update it we can go
back
yeah let's do that add record page very
quickly
uh down here let's just create another
button
and instead of saying add record let's
have it say back no actually let's go to
our record page and let's grab this back
guy because this is an actual link which
is easier
and we're just going to copy and paste
all right save that now let me come back
here and hit reload it says back yeah
that's nice all right and we're good to
go we've got the link here to click on
the ID maybe you want Mary Smith to be
clickable as well or instead we could do
that go to our home page and
come up here and let's just grab this
link and like I said we could easily
just as easily add it to our first name
and then close it right here
save this and back over here it reload
now the names are clickable instead of
the ID when we click on John Elder it
goes to John Elder
we could you know just as easily put
another column here that says click here
to update if you wanted to update from
this page we could do that as well it's
trivia I'll leave that to you I'm going
to take this out because I think that's
kind of ugly
I'm just gonna hit undo a couple of
times here save this head back over here
hit reload and we are good to go now one
last thing let's push all this final
code to GitHub so you have the updated
code
so to do that let's go get add period so
get commit Dash am and let's say final
project
whatever and then get push to push it up
to GitHub
let me run our server again just so that
it's running in the background now if we
come back over here go to github.com
forward slash flatplanet
and let's just do it like that
click on repositories
and then Django CRM
the complete final code is here that's
github.com forward slash flatplanet
forward slash Django Dash CRM there you
can find the totally completed code if
you like this
head over to codemy.com I have got like
over a dozen other Django courses if
you're into Django stuff basic Django
create a dental website Django to-do
list app Django authentication a whole
course just on authentication but we
pretty much covered everything here well
no we didn't actually there's more stuff
in there that's interesting stock market
app flash card app push your code to a
Roku app a weather app cryptocurrency
that's kind of outdated build an API
here's a couple of chat GPT courses this
one we created a code bot that chat GPT
will write code for you and give it to
you it's really cool this one is just
the basic chat bot so if you're
interested in Django check all those out
like I said you can always sign up for
membership
by clicking on lifetime membership which
is usually 249 dollars if you come over
here and type in YouTube 50 you get half
off so you get all of my courses over 50
courses and all my future courses at no
extra charge for a one-time fee of 125
which is pretty fantastic or you could
sign up for monthly for 12 bucks a month
you could get individual courses for 49
each or you can get yearly membership
for 99 bucks but honestly if you're
going to get yearly for 99 you might as
well sign up for a toll for just 25
bucks more or whatever 26 bucks more
that gets you all my future courses I've
got an aggressive course release
schedule this year 2023-24 so I'm trying
to release at least one if not two new
courses every month and so far we've
been able to do that and uh should be
good so all right I think we're gonna
call this guy done
pretty simple app but all kinds of cool
functionality in here and this is basic
crud applications create read update and
Destroy so we can create a record
right
we can read a record
yeah we can update it record yeah
and we can delete a record crud create
read update destroy if you're interested
in all things web development everything
on the internet is a crud application
create read update and destroy a
Facebook post is nothing more than crud
you create a Facebook post you read a
Facebook post sometimes you update a
Facebook Facebook post or sometimes you
delete a Facebook post everything
Twitter you can actually update a
Twitter tweet can you yeah
Instagram everything is just crud and
this is how you do crud and Django
pretty simple pretty straightforward and
very fun so that's all for this video if
you liked it be sure to smash like
button below subscribe to the channel
give me a thumbs up for the YouTube
algorithm and check out codemy.com or
you can use coupon code you do 50 to get
50 off membership so that's access to
all my courses over 50 courses thousands
of videos and the PDFs of all my
best-selling coding books doing over 150
000 students learning to code just like
you my name is John Elder from
codemy.com and I'll see you in the next
video